U.S prosecutors are considering whether
to file formal criminal charges against
former president Donald Trump a
congressional panel has recommended four
counts over Trump's role in the January
6th Insurrection Trump has dismissed the
referral as fake charges saying the
democrat-led committee is trying to
block his possible return to campaigning
[Applause]
these images shocked the world two years
ago thousands of supporters of former
president Donald Trump stormed the U.S
capital aiming to overturn the 2020
election and stop the peaceful transfer
of power
[Applause]
five people died in the attack including
Capital police officers whose sole
responsibility was to protect members of
Congress the vice president and their
staff
six months later Congress established
the so-called January 6 committee to
investigate the events that led to the
attack
committee got straight to work
conducting over a thousand interviews
and holding 10 public hearings they
released previously unseen footage
documenting the harrowing hours inside
the building
and they highlighted the former
president's lack of action to stop the
riot even accusing him of helping to
carry out the attack we gotta walk down
to the Capitol I hope we've helped make
clear that there's a broader kind of
accountability
accountability to all of you the
American people
the future of our democracy rests in
your hands it's up to the people of this
country to decide who deserves the
public Trust
January 6th 2021 was the first time one
American president refused his
constitutional duty to transfer power
peacefully to the next
in our work over the last 18 months the
select committee has recognized Our
obligation to do everything we can to
ensure this never happens again the
committee recommended criminal charges
for former president Donald Trump but it
will be up to the U.S justice department
to decide whether he will actually end
up in court
I told him the report is highly symbolic
and it will have long lasting effects on
Trump's political Ambitions all I want
to do is this for many Republicans so
supporting a candidate facing criminal
charges may be a bridge too far
off more on this I'm joined Now by DW's
Washington bureau chief Ennis Paul Ennis
good to see you I want to start by
asking if you think the attorney
Attorney General will actually prosecute
Donald Trump on these charges
well Anthony the U.S is in the very
early stages of this extremely
complicated process as we just heard the
January 6 committee announced its
unprecedented recommendation to reformer
president Trump for four uh different uh
criminal charges the justice department
is already working on cases against
Trump and also his associates so we do
not know what stage they are in or if
they plan to move forward with any
charges but Anthony I think it is fair
to say that this is still a Monumental
moment on Capitol Hill
yeah you make the point that we don't
know exactly where we are in this
landscape but if we take it to its end
the scenario would these charges could
these charges stop Trump from running
again for president
well if if the president were took a
charge for inciting an Insurrection
sorry which was one of the four
recommended charges he would be
disqualified from running for office
again but at this stage at this very
moment nothing can prevent him from
continuing to pursue to hold public
office
Enos Trump has painted the investigation
as a political Witch Hunt another one
but could this actually help him if he
does run again
it's a good question Anthony I mean
amongst his deepest and uh most loyal
supporters uh he continues to be
extremely popular and this might
actually
embolden them as Trump looks to take
back the White House but we also have to
keep in mind uh that during the midterms
in November that the most voters
rejected actually Trump endorsed
candidates who campaigned that the
election was stolen so it is likely that
the majority of the Republican party
members are rather turning their back
against Donald Trump you've been witness
to all of this uh do you think this
investigation can deepen America's
political divide even further from where
it is now
recently the chief of the capital police
testified in front of the Senate and
said that there were more than 9 000
threats against lawmakers this past year
I think this shows How Deep The Divide
is and how dangerous it is here in the
United States
the AWS Washington Bureau Chef Venus
Paul thanks so much
let's bring in Marcus Keim he's a senior
fellow at the German Institute for
international and security Affairs
welcome to you let me start by asking if
you think the Attorney General will
actually prosecute Donald Trump on these
charges
that's a good question and in my view
one of the key questions I mean you may
you already made a reference the
recommendation of the committee is
non-binding so the Department of
Justice does not have to do anything it
can press jardless or it can
and in political concerns I think the
bidengo administration will very
carefully consider political options I
think since the midterm elections it has
become clear to a wider public that
Donald Trump is more of a falling star
than a rising star that his time is more
or less over despite his public
appearances and his resonance in The
Wider US public
so they have to calculate that by
pressing titles they might fuel his
political momentum anything they would
like to avoid and therefore I think they
I could imagine that the Department of
Justice will be quite hesitant to do
anything about it and I will keep it as
a political recommendation and not as a
legal obligation
to answer the next scenario I guess we
need to play out the scenario a little
though if these charges go ahead would
they stop Trump running again
no not at all I think it um there's
already an investigation going on led by
the department Department of classes and
we cannot foresee how long this
investigation will go so it might take
longer than the election campaign the
next it actually could be might think
longer than the next election date uh we
will have to see and it's quite
difficult to assess or this will
impact the electric bin of Donald Trump
and the effect might be might be exactly
the country it will deepen the division
of the United States Society it will
deepen polarization or fuel polarization
in the United States and by doing this
we'll fuel the
um the momentum of the of the Trump
campaign so he might end up stronger
than he is currently
Marcus came thank you so much for your
time
my pleasure